to be able to sign somewhere and still
put stuff out independently now for
people who don't know you're on def jam
now mm-hmm
you did a deal with def jam
um
but this album
this j cole song
which might end up being your biggest
song ever because cole's on it right you
just be honest like the streams might go
[ __ ] out of this world
it's on empire yeah still indy
[Music]
what the [ __ ] going on how'd you break
the system man i mean it's like
i mean that's where the game at right
now you know what i mean where the
underground [ __ ] with the industry [ __ ]
and i'm saying you see dudes like
babyface ray or
you know what i mean just
i could keep naming a whole bunch of
[ __ ] who just
like you know i mean so my thing is like
you obviously have to negotiate that
with def gym
but like tana talk four is a big album
for you so why the [ __ ] wouldn't they be
like nah we need that over here like
because
they [ __ ] with me and they trust me and
they believe in me it's about this it's
like
now
coming from my point of view i need to i
need to
i put my name on that paper you know i
owe
and i'm saying so it's like this i owe
obligations to them and they owe
obligations to me so to fulfill my
obligations i need to walk in there with
this uh tana talk four patch already on
my cape i'm also assuming the tana talk
four thing was already worked out with
yeah and that's another thing
basically i'm just saying is that once
you explain to these people your plans
they they understand it you know what
i'm saying like okay you get what you
negotiate you get what you negotiate
they respect that you know what i mean
like okay you're gonna do that and then
you're gonna come over here like yeah
trust me you know i'm letting them know
like i'm about to smoke this and then
i'm coming over here i mean like how
many albums do you owe def jam
one that's it yeah
one
god man
shout out to mike i've been
what